i don't mean to sound desperate on maine  or not but i really do have an  internship  for a tick-tocker  me at my marketing company  yeah this is the logo of my marketing my  favorite color i'm in my office at my  marketing company  i am offering to pay you money  to join my marketing company on an  internship to promote a really cool  brand  and i would really hope that maybe at  this point you could stitch me yeah and  tell me that you want to be my intern i  want to be your in the spring semester  yes or you just want a part-time job  being a tick-tocker yeah i quit that's  totally fine with me too  the money is the same whether you're  getting college credit for it or you  just want to put into your bank account  me pick